if you look at iron man's first suit the
mark 1
and compare it to the hero's nanotech
suit from avengers in-game
a lot has changed but it's not just the
technology in the world of the mcu
animation tech has evolved in our world
the real world
to make this suit possible on the big
screen
something that marvel couldn't have
dreamed of creating just 11 years
earlier
to get from here to here required a
decade of innovation
10 marvel movies and a lot of work on
movies with no superhero in sight
let's start where tony stark's story
began
in that cave in 2008's iron man
in this scene tony stark is a man in a
giant metal suit
trying to escape a cave so what better
way to make it seem real
than by using a real man in a real metal
suit
iron man director john favreau is known
for pushing the envelope
with his projects like the lion king and
the mandalorian
but back then he wasn't confident that
cgi
could convincingly create a full ironman
suit
so they went practical for that first
bulky cave suit
he enlisted the help of the legendary
stan winston studio
now called legacy effects to make this
90 pound version of the mark 1
with epoxy armor shells flexible
urethane
leather and aluminum and for the project
winston's team perfected a metallic
chrome paint that would be used for
other projects
years down the road but the film had to
rely on cgi for this section of the
scene
because the practical suit was just too
large for either robert downey jr
or his stunt double to move around in
that left the challenge of creating the
first
digital iron man suit audiences would
see
up to the embassy in vancouver their
accomplishment wouldn't have been
possible without the practical work from
stan winston studio
they modeled the digital suit closely
after the real suit
even going so far as getting pieces of
that real suit flown to canada for
reference
the digital version was so detailed that
it even captures
these text markings and textures and to
create a realistic metallic reflection
the embassy used the knowledge they
learned from working on car commercials
to influence how they
shaded the digital version of the suit
we learned a lot about car paint
about clear coat how light plays on cars
how
they rack to their environment which
they're essentially mirrors of their
environment but that was just the mark
one
the mark ii would have to be sleeker and
more refined
and have a polished coat that would
accurately reflect light
like the night sky in this scene once
again
favreau had stan winston create a real
version of this suit
but what you're looking at here is
completely computer generated
just like with the mark 1 fx studio
industrial light and magic
ilm for short used that practical
version of the suit as the basis for its
digital version
ilm was so successful that when favreau
saw it he couldn't tell the difference
between the real and the fake
and we showed it to john and the marvel
team and they're like okay well which
bits did you replace
and we're like actually we replaced the
whole thing
without this early work in the first
iron man which convinced the filmmakers
and the world of what vfx could do the
wild world of marvel as we know it
might not exist but the true
test of the cgi would come with the mark
iii
iron man's most recognizable look this
had to be
perfect for the film to work and
resonate with fans
ilm wanted to prove both that they could
make the cgi
character move the right way and that
his metal
armor matched the personality of tony
stark
ilm had worked with shiny car surfaces
in 2007's transformers
which ultimately helped them nail down
the outer layer of the mark
iii they made the suit look more like a
glossy sports car
than industrial metal as marvel
initially planned
we ended up saying you know what it's
tony stark he's a playboy
you know he's rich he's not gonna have
an industrial forklift
type suit he's gonna want a sports car
suit the basic design was based on
marvel comic book artist adi granov's
iron man illustrations
but one of the biggest challenges with
replicating this 2d suit in real life
was that the comic version was designed
with heroic proportions
that don't match real human beings so
they tweaked the model to be shaped as
if a real human being were inside
something they would later decide to
change but when it came to iron man
we tried to be very like oh no a real
guy could fit in the suit
and the real mechanism between the
suit and the guy is there now the guy
would have to be
extremely thin to really fit into it
at the onset of iron man 2 motion
capture technology had really advanced
which made it possible for them to use a
combination of practical and cgi
suits various practical versions of the
mark iii
suit were built by stan winston's team
which could be worn in pieces based on
which parts of robert downey jr were
seen on camera at the time
the rest of his body was often covered
in a motion capture suit
which would be filled in later with cg
suit pieces
this would help his performance since he
didn't have to struggle
under the bulk and weight of the full
suit ilm
used its custom motion capture
technology
called imo cap which they had fine-tuned
in 2003's pirates of the caribbean
to animate the cg parts of the suit
since robert downey jr's head
wasn't animated it had to match up
perfectly
or else it would look wobbly and disjoin
it
in several of the films robert downey jr
often just wore
these shoulder pads or what they called
a football suit
these shots required a lot of cgi
cleanup on the spaces in between
like his neck and joints vfx artists
really advanced the motion tracking in
iron man 2
and you can see a good example of that
here in this japanese garden scene
the actors only wore partial helmets and
tracking suits
the rest of their suits are cgi and in
this particular scene
ilm didn't even need to use a tracking
suit at all
they built the cgi suit right around
robert downey jr
who was only wearing a tuxedo this took
a lot of time and effort to get right
but it ultimately set the bar for future
films
in terms of what they could animate
without mocap suits
another major improvement from the first
film in iron man 2
was the shading or how the suit was lit
ilm started using
image-based lighting tools they
developed from their work on 2009's
terminator salvation
to light the suit and make it look more
realistic
this process involved taking high-res
pictures of the environment
and using those as a guide to more
accurately and easily light the suit
this ultimately helped iron man look
even better
allowing them more time to focus on the
finer details
it meant that we were able to speed up
our process and spend a lot more time
making things creatively look good
instead of you know just like oh is it
even looking
real or not not only did the animation
evolve as the vfx technology advanced
but each new film also posed new
challenges for animators based on the
story
for instance when it came to 2012's the
avengers
it was the script that pushed how the
character would be designed
and animated instead of hand thrusters
iron man would get a rocket
pack attached to the back of his suit
which allowed the design team
leeway to develop new poses for the
character while freeing up the hero's
hands
or take a look at this sequence known
internally as the car wash scene
because of this brand new way marvel
writers envisioned how tony's suit would
attach to him
animators for the first time had to
figure out how the inside of iron man's
suit would function
which none of the vfx studios marvel
worked with had to think much about
before
we had to build a lot of new interior
pieces kind of figure out like what the
interior tech of the suit would look
like as it
as it joined together this was
particularly challenging
since he's walking the entire time while
de-suiting
a first in the series ilm had to create
models for each piece of the suit and
track them individually with his
movement
and take a look at this battle scene
with thor in the mountaintop
notice all of the blue light the minor
detail caused a major headache with
animators at weta digital when it came
to coloring iron man's suit
marvel maintains a strict color bible
which keeps track of the exact hues that
are supposed to be used across the
various films
the brushed gold surface here was based
on weta digital's work
on the one ring in lord of the rings and
they were able to recreate this color
fairly easily but the red on the other
hand
it's actually a red clear coat which
means that
the red the red pigment itself actually
has density
um and on top of that there's actually
little little
metal shavings suspended in that dense
paint which can cause problems when you
mix in
light from the environment in this case
the red and blue
made purple you know one of the first
things we ran into back then was that
you take a suit like that and put a blue
light on it and
it starts to give you weird colors it
starts to want to go really
burgundy you know sort of a mulberry
color very fast
balancing the color would end up being
much easier and
faster in the later films as weta
develops new advanced rendering
technology that worked with various
wavelengths of light
and this as was the case with ilm and
its shading technology
would make the suit look better overall
we could spend a lot of time
trying to make that car paint look just
a little bit cooler or try to make the
lighting work a little bit better
and not just trying to get rid of weird
shadows or weird colors
while the earlier films mostly focused
on the movements of one individual suit
iron man 3 introduced a whole slew of
new suits
about 20 in a single scene that each had
to be animated in different ways
typically to animate iron man they would
use what's called a puppet
and there's a limited number of ways
this puppet can move
sowetta developed new tools for its
animators to use to alter the rig of the
puppet
to increase the freedom of movement so
each suit could have more character and
style
we rejig the entire process to
allow the animator to go in and take the
high resolution suit and just
you know like with an x-acto knife he'd
cut on different planes and
cut different parts of it out and put
hinges on them on the fly so that he
could actually
uh you know the animator could define
how the suit grew
one of the challenges that comes with
more freedom of movement however
is making sure iron man's metal plates
don't run into each other
and figuring out where all the pieces go
when he does a simple motion
like raising his arm i think the main
challenge we had
on iron man 3 was the shoulders
he had used huge shoulder pad but it
wasn't just these major
battle scenes that were difficult they
often had to also spend time
figuring out how he moved in more
mundane scenarios
we saw for the first time in iron man 3
scenes where he is doing these very
non-heroic actions
like giving a massage or simply sitting
on a couch
it's easier to hide any errors and
subtleties in a cloud of dust or debris
according to ilm
when he isn't fighting someone every
detail is right out there in the open
iron man 3 also had tony stark reacting
and performing along with the suit
assembly for the first time
a step up from the walking car wash
scene in the avengers
as marvel wanted an even more advanced
look to the tech
this was especially difficult according
to vfx studio trickster
since they had to combine rigid metal
pieces and flexible human body parts
while making it all look seamless
24 separate parts were first disguised
as what trickster calls
amorphous mystery slick pieces of
technology
alien to any distinguishable suit parts
each would then transform into the
familiar suit pieces as they flew
towards him
as the series evolved from using
practical effects in iron man
to a mix of practical and cgi to mostly
cgi in later films
suddenly the suit which was originally
tweaked to be more human
would now be tweaked to be more heroic
again we first saw subtle changes in the
avengers with his legs
a little little facts that a lot of
people probably don't know
iron man's legs are longer than a
human's legs his ankle would also have
to be a mere
inch and a half across inside the suit
iron man was
also slimmed down a bit in avengers age
of ultron
to give him more of a comic superhero
silhouette slightly tighter waist
that sort of thing a little beefier
around the shoulders but the suit
evolved yet again
in the last two films forcing the
animators to evolve as well
and take a whole different approach to
how the suit would build and move
tony stark was now using nanotechnology
so instead of moving around and tracking
solid pieces like they did with the car
wash scene
and the scene in his workshop they had
to establish a whole new process for his
suit assembly
nanotech involves multiple layers of
simulations
a liquid metal simulation would morph to
the target shape
because they wanted the transformation
to feel organic but they had to make
sure
it still felt rigid and that it did not
stretch like spider-man's suit would
the animators relied on accurate shading
a technique used throughout the
franchise to accomplish this
main visual trickery is that through the
shading we
it looked like metal every single time
robert downey jr reportedly came up with
the idea of having tony stark's
sweatsuit
tightened before the armor shell appears
similar to spiderman's suit which you
can see here
because it would be difficult for the
material to form a shell around loose
clothing
if you look closely octagonal shapes
attach together to form the outer layer
while an inner layer of tech and
circuitry built beneath it
frame store actually created this
multi-layer effect
using animation tools from its work on
2015's poltergeist
for in-game this nanotech suit evolved
slightly to be a bit more rigid
with pieces locking into place more like
the suit we saw in captain america civil
war
we took the lessons that we learned from
infinity war and applied it
to endgame so it was the same technology
really but
we just had a better handle of it while
iron man's death was the last time we
would see the nanotech suit
this wouldn't be the last time we saw
iron man as marvel's innovation
continued for his one final cameo
in spider-man far from home
this suit was also created by frame
store and it was actually based on the
suit in captain america civil war
because it was more solid looking than
the nanotech suit in avengers in-game
to make this suit they took the same
civil war model
and literally broke it down destroyed it
and created the
incise which consisted of various wires
and circuit boards
using an early scene in age of ultron as
inspiration
there is more detail in the top half of
the suit
because more of that is shown up close
on camera
and to achieve the undead look first
they added the signature metallic sheen
of iron man
and then they added the layers of dirt
and rust to be fair the shoot is
almost not recognizable by the end of
the process
so after 11 years of development to
perfect iron man's cgi suit
it ultimately was destroyed
by using advancements in 3d modeling and
motion tracking
experimenting with new lighting
techniques
and using realistic-looking practical
models as a base
they were able to create something that
continually felt fresh
futuristic and real as it evolved in the
story
it wasn't like anybody had thought that
a person could wear a suit of powered
armor and it would look anything other
than like a guy an old night armor
wobbling around on a set he's so crafted
on so many levels there's so much
thought that goes into every little
panel that moves
that you're you're intrigued and you're
compelled to keep watching them and find
out what's going to happen